.
dede Montréal avec le sourire!
(a(acclamations)
- - Une autre qui a gagné son
papari, c'est à Montréal.
OnOn retrouve tout de suite la
mamairesse réélue, Valérie Plan.
BoBonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Madame Plante, on vous
reretrouve dans quel état d'espt
auaujourd'hui? Vous ait fatigué,
vovous êtes heureuse, la battere
esest plus faible qu'hier?
- - J'ai envie de vous dire
tetellement fière et heureuse.
CeCette victoire, elle est
écéclatante, cette majorité quea
popopulation nous donne, il lesa
e et les arrondissements que ln
memet de l'avant, et le résulta,
çaça me touche énormément parce
quque non seulement j'ai été la
mamairesse pendant les quatre
dedernières années mais j'ai aui
trtravaillé la pandémie avec les
gegens. J'avoue que ça me touche
etet je prends à nouveau ce mant
avavec beaucoup d'humilité est e
grgrande responsabilité à laquee
jeje veux faire honneur.
- - Avec un gain de plus
auaujourd'hui dans Côte-des-Neis
NoNotre-Dame de grâce. Il s'est
papassé quelque chose. Votre
cacandidate qui a été élue,
elelle affrontait Lionel Perez i
ététait quand même le chef du
paparti d'opposition. Il a perd.
NoNon seulement Monsieur Coderra
peperdu mais en plus,
cecelui qui était chef
d'd'opposition a perdu. Quelle
lelecture vous fait de cela?
- - Je crois que les citoyens ot
clclairement dit à tous les
cacandidats confondus que la
nonotion même de prendre soin de
lala vie de quartier, de la mete
enen valeur, de souhaiter de la
mimixité économique, culturelle,
gégénérationnel, via le logemen,
vivia le transportrt, via des
seservices à la population,
vivia la transition écologique,
c'c'est important. On a toujours
étété un parti qui mettait les
cicitoyens et la vie de quartieà
l'l'avant-plan comme étant pas
ququelque chose de petit outil
inintéressant mais comme étant e
vavaleur fondamentalement...
fofondamental qui fait rayonner
MoMontréal.
- - On a juste un petit problème
dede son ici. Je veux m'assurer
ququ'on vous entend bien. Voilà.
- - Je me suis accroché.
- - Est-ce que Denis Coderre a
chcherché à vous contacter?
- - Voilà, hier, lorsque j'ai
cocontacté Monsieur Coderre, mes
adadversaires, j'ai laissé un
memessage à Denis épuis n'ayant
papas de ses nouvelles, je lui i
enenvoyé un petit texto ce matin
enen lui disant : je t'ai envoyé
unun message, rappelle moi.
FiFinalement, il y a quelques
miminutes, j'ai reçu une réponse
papar texto et l'important, c'et
ququ'à partir de ce moment, la
popopulation a parlé, c'est un
exexercice démocratique et on
avavance.
- - Qu'est-ce qu'il dit dans son
tetexto?
- - Il me souhaite bonne chance.
IlIl va avoir plusieurs défis pr
MoMontréal dans les prochaines
anannées et il souhaite vraiment
quque tous les partis, tous les
élélus travaillent ensemble, ce
quque je souhaite également
arardemment parce qu'il y a des
dédéfis pour moi et il y a des
sosolutions.
- - Mais on ne sait pas si
MoMonsieur Coderre reste ou pasn
popolitique municipale?
- - Vous avait raison. Je ne sas
papas. On n'a pas parlé de cela.
- - Clairement.
VoVous avez une majorité très
clclaire au conseil. Qu'est-ce e
çaça vous donne comme avantage?
- - Dans notre premier mandat, n
avait déjà une majorité et on a
vuvu ce que nous a permis de
fafaire. On a acheté des terrais
dansns l'Ouest. On a pu mettre e
pipied sur l'accélérateur sur ds
prprojets importants.
C'est sûr que pour nous, ça nous
dodonne ce levier pour les
prprochaines années. Et justeme,
ququand il est question de
trtransition écologique, il faut
fafaire le grand chahangement.
JeJe l'ai fait avec l'ensemble s
élélus mais ça nous donne les
coudées franches. Évidemment, le
rarapport de force que l'on peut
avavoir avec Québec et Ottawa, l
esest très présent.
DaDans mon résultat personnel à
tititre de mairesse, 52 %,
c'c'est important. Et aussi
d'd'avoir cette majorité, ça nos
pepermet d'avoir une conversatin
enencore plus franche et directe
avavec les autres paliers de
gogouvernement.
- - Êtes-vous devenu une
pepersonnalité incontournable
cocomme l'était Régis Labeaume?l
fafallait la voir de son côté
ququand on était en politique.
EsEst-ce que c'est en train de
dedevenir la même chose avec
MoMontréal et vous?
- - Il y a des gens qui incarnet
lele rôle de mère ou de mairesse
mamais aussi quelle ville on
rereprésentera dans le cas de
RéRégis, de par son expérience
etet aussi étant la capitale, et
dadans mon cas, étant la
mémétropole, c'est un
inincontournable. Nous sommes
inincontournables nécessairement
mamais c'est évident que ce
dedeuxième mandat, forte de
l'l'expérience, des apprentissas
paparce que j'ai appris vraiment
bebeaucoup de choses,
nénécessairement, ça va très bin
meme servir au cours des
prprochaines années.
- - Les couronnes de Montréal
mamaintenant, il y a des nouveax
mamaires aussi, une nouvelle
gégénération. Vous partagez
plplusieurs priorités,
l'l'environnement, la transition
écécologique, le transport en
cocommun, habitation et les
lologements. Ça va vous donner
ququand même une force de frappe
dadans le discours, d'avoir des
alalliés, vous allez représenter
plplus que Montréal.
- - Absolument.
EÉvidemment, comme le respect qe
jeje suis déjà la présidente dea
cocommunauté métropolitaine de
MoMontréal et j'ai travaillé trs
fofort pour amener des enjeux de
trtransition écologique et
d'd'habitation à l'avant-p-plan.
MaMais c'est évident
quque les nouveaux maires et
mamairesses qui ont cette
prpréoccupation, et quand on
reregarde en fait, il y a des
bebelles choses qui se sont
papassées durant cette campagne
élélectorale à la grandeur du
QuQuébec. Ce sont des agendas
vrvraiment connectés à la
trtransition écologique il
hahabitation comme on n'a jamais
vuvu auparavant. Pour moi, c'est
poporteur d'avenir. Ça veut dire
quque tout le monde, petite ou
grgrande municipalité, on se
prpréoccupe, c'est ce que les
cicitoyens demandent. Évidemmen,
dadans mon rôle de métropole et
cocomme mairesse de Montréal,
évévidemment, j'ai bien
l'l'intention de continuer à jor
cece rôle de leader pour partagr
dedes outils, des apprentissage,
papar avancée des grandes
dodossiers